Goodman host of Pacifica radios
Democracy Now talks to Raj Patel author
of the value of nothing and Naomi Klein
author of the Shock Doctrine about their
books the economy the earthquake in
Haiti and other topics
what a great honor it is to thin your
hair now what a great honor it is to be
here with two colleagues who are my
media heroes and to be here on this cold
night that proves that those meetings in
Copenhagen were about something very
real yes the whole issue of it's better
to talk about I think climate disruption
than global warming when we're having
these kind of Arctic nights but let me
introduce our two guests tonight Naomi
Klein is a remarkable public
intellectual scholar and activist her
work is both groundbreaking and
breathtaking when Yomi was in Iraq as
the rest of the pundits were talking
about President Bush not knowing what he
was doing she came out saying no he has
a very clear plan
she wrote a piece in Harper's Magazine
called Baghdad Year Zero pillaging a
rock in pursuit of a neocon utopia she
broke through that small circle of
pundits that were used to seeing on all
the channels who know so little about so
much explaining the world to us and
getting it so wrong that's right she
broke through with what very few people
have on television that's
facts that no one else seems to dig up
she so eloquently elucidates what the
real plans are but Naomi Klein is not
just a critic she's a chronicler and a
leader of grassroots movements around
the world with her husband avi Lewis
they did the film the take about
Argentina and the retaking of the
factories there before that she wrote
the book no logo and tonight here in New
York she's celebrating the 10th
anniversary of that publication which is
as relevant or perhaps more relevant
today than it was 10 years ago as the
rest of the media was saying what is the
Battle of Seattle Naomi had already
written a book about it a character in
john lecarre a's novel absolute friends
recommends naomi klein as the top of the
reading that should be done if you want
to understand post-cold-war
corporate power and I think her latest
book certainly proves that the Shock
Doctrine the rise of disaster
capitalists remarkable Shatterer
they purposely introducing Raj second
because they didn't want to just come
out here and say tonight we're talking
about the value of nothing though that
is the title of his new book the value
of nothing how to reshape market society
and redefine democracy and I was really
excited to hear that he's just learned
that it's hit the New York Times
bestseller list
there is hope and people do care Raj
Patel is the author of stuffed and
starved he's an activist and an academic
has been hailed as a visionary for his
foresight when it came to the food
crisis and one of the things we're going
to talk about we'll begin with is Haiti
and he talks eloquently about what
happened in Haiti Raj has worked for the
World Bank and the World Trade
Organization and protested both on four
continents
he is currently a visiting scholar at UC
Berkeley's Center for african-american
studies for African Studies and an
honorary research fellow at the School
of Development Studies at the University
of kwazulu-natal he's also a fellow at
the Institute for food and development
policy also known as food first and most
importantly his wife is about to have a
baby his partners about have a baby any
day
and it's nice to be able and smile to
smile and celebrate life on a very
difficult night like tonight where who
knows exactly what is the death toll in
Haiti the horror that started unfolding
last night about five o'clock when we
learned that there had been an
earthquake
I think card four is the epicenter and
now the numbers we don't even know it
could be a hundred thousand one Haitian
official was saying of people who have
died the Archbishop of Haiti was killed
the head of the UN mission was killed
and we don't know certainly anywhere
near the number of people as people are
being dug out as the wails are still
being heard and that's where I think we
should begin tonight because both of you
have so eloquently talked about the
issue I think it's interesting Naomi in
your book the Shock Doctrine though you
didn't address it I was asking you about
him he said actually it was a chapter
that she had written and ended up
writing for the Nation magazine on Haiti
but I think we're really talking about
twin earthquakes here twin crises that
have rocked Haiti one is the natural
catastrophe that they are dealing with
today the worst earthquake in what two
centuries but then there is what is
human-made and that is the earthquake
the hurricane the crisis of poverty and
how that exacerbates the effect of this
earthquake and that's where I wanted to
start with Raj Patel and stuffed and
starve you write about Haiti talk about
what we should understand the corporate
media does a good job of getting there
and showing us the horror of what's
happening and you should demand of all
the networks that they stick with it so
that we know
do care people are hungry for
information about what is happening to
our fellow and sister human beings in
Haiti
I think that's proven over and over
again so we're seeing this natural
catastrophe unfold but put it in the
context of the politics of this poorest
country in the Western Hemisphere Haiti
was an inspiration I mean it's important
to remember that Haiti was the site of
the first slave rebellion and the
rebellion in 1794 is something that we
need to absolutely continue to be
inspired by
but for that it has been relentlessly
punished by the country by by Europe and
then by the United States and it's a
country that that's been through a
prolonged occupation by the United
States and the weapons that the United
States is most recently leveled against
Haiti have been predominantly economic
Haiti at the beginning of the 1980s grew
the majority of its own rice it was a
country that was able to grow and able
to sustain the majority of its
population domestically but because the
people of Haiti had made choices about a
government that were that was left-wing
and wanted wanted to have a left-wing
government it was punished by two six
two US presidents President Reagan and
Clinton and both those presidents
imposed economic structural adjustment
policies that meant that Haiti was
forced to open up it it's certainly it's
food markets to to the so-called free
market of course there is no free market
in food and us in the u.s. rice industry
according to the Cato Institute in some
years gets almost a billion dollars a
year in subsidy and so on the one hand
you had Haitian rice farmers some of the
poorest people on a certain in the
Western Hemisphere
who were forced to compete against US
rice farmers getting a billion dollars a
year in subsidy and so it it's not
surprising that the Haitian rice farmers
read the economic signals clearly and
first started by exploiting themselves
and then
responded by going to the cities and
abandoning farming the only rice farming
that exists now in Haiti is subsistence
it's not not for the market um and so
Haiti was intentionally made dependent
on on US rice imports and then of course
when the price of rice went up in 2008
by 30 percent in a single day on the
international market there were what
were called food riots or what I've
termed with some colleagues of food
first food rebellions and those
rebellions were obviously demands for
rice but they were also expressions of
political change demands for political
change and in fact every so-called food
riot always has a political component to
it I mean the news media will make it to
a food riot so-called after after it's
happened and what they will see is
pictures of tires burning in the road
and then there'll be some breathless
urgent commentary on and the people were
just here and you won't believe what
they were doing and they were trying to
smash their way in to get getting food
and of course access to food is always a
part of a food riot but the food the
food protests in Haiti were also
politically articulate demands for the
return of jean-bertrand Aristide
the the I mean who was displaced in a
serious in fact of view not not just
once displacing the series of coos and
these these politically articulate
protests have been systematically
stamped out and so what we have in Haiti
is a long history of US intervention of
using markets as a means to subjugate
the population and to punish the
population for their own desire for
autonomy and and yet of course in the
reconstructed media picture Haitians are
portrayed not as part political
politically articulate and organized and
thoughtful but merely as people running
from one chaos you know but chaotic
scene to another in search of food and
that's something that we need absolutely
to redress in and so when we see these
images on on TV we need to insist not
only that the media portray portray
what's actually happening but give the
context before we talk about
how Haiti fits into your idea of the
Shock Doctrine now me just a little back
history you talked about Haiti being the
born out of a slave uprising in 1804 the
US Congress for decades would not
recognize the Republic of Haiti because
it was born of a slave uprising and the
Congress members in the US Congress were
afraid it would inspire us slaves to
rise up nineteen fifteen to thirty four
the first u.s. occupation by the US
Marines of Haiti and then when president
Aristide was elected in nineteen ninety
the almost immediate within a year coup
that has been proven was also backed by
the Central Intelligence Agency our
steed was forced out for three years 91
to 94 came back to serve out his term
what about a year I directly had the
experience of the second time president
Aristide was forced out in 2004 because
I followed a small delegation when he
was whisked onto a plane by US military
and security with the first lady Mildred
IRA steed and they were flown off to
they didn't know where the sent turned
out to be the Central African Republic
bangy the capital where they were held
basically in captivity the small
delegation led by Congress member Maxine
Waters will have her on Democracy Now
tomorrow to talk about what her thinking
on Haiti is right now Congress member
Maxine Waters and Randall Robinson the
founder of trans Africa along with
Jamaican parliamentarian who is coming
with an invitation for the heiress needs
to return to this hemisphere to come to
Jamaica I followed them in a plane an
all too small plane we flew from from
Miami cross the ocean to senegal dakar
senegal and cape verde and we ended up
in banki the central african republic
where they went to retrieve the our
steeds and actually succeeded and as we
flew back through Africa and across the
Atlantic
and ultimately landed in Jamaica the
threats were coming in fast and furious
from the Bush administration from
Secretary of State Colin Powell and
others and Rumsfeld who were saying if
the our steeds the our steeds were not
to enter this hemisphere - which Randall
Robinson said on the plane whose
hemisphere and we're certainly not to
come near Haiti whose country the our
steeds returned to Jamaica but were
ultimately not able to go back to Haiti
and they now live in South Africa and
exile so that is the story of the
attempts at democracy in Haiti how would
you put that Naomi Klein into the
context of the Shock Doctrine the rise
of disaster capitalism and take it right
through now from the Hurricanes to this
earthquake well thank you Amy and you
know that history is so important that
you both provided in terms of
understanding this particular political
moment and some of the things we really
need to watch for as the world rightly
rushes to Hades aid because it we are in
this context of really centuries of
trying to bend Haiti to our will to
Western will to discipline this fiercely
independent country using all means
available and debt has always been the
primary tool of disciplining Haiti from
its period of independence to the extent
that you know we have these debates you
know in this country about reparations
for slavery and the right of African
Americans to be paid in some form for
the theft of their ancestors and the
broken promise of 40 acres and a mule
what we often don't hear is that
liberated slaves in many cases had to
pay reparations to their former owners
for their freedom and the great
example of that is Haiti when Haiti was
forced to pay reparations to France so
it began in this debt it was never
actually free and this has been an
ongoing battle and in fact you know our
speed I mean this was one of the one of
the theories about why France was so
determined to get rid of him was that
and the US was the the precedent there
was a lawsuit that he was he was in the
process of suing the French government
for the original sort of odious debt
that was imposed on Haiti it became more
sophisticated over the years in his Raj
spoke about that structural adjustment
policies became the tool for
disciplining Haiti but as I read about
in the Shock Doctrine crises are often
used now as the pretext for for pushing
through policies that you cannot push
through under times of stability
countries in periods of extreme crisis
are desperate for any kind of aid any
kind of money and are not in a position
to negotiate fairly the terms of that
exchange and I just want to pause for a
second and read you something which is
pretty extraordinary I just put this up
on on my website the headline is Haiti
stop them before they shock again this
went up a few hours ago three hours ago
I believe on the Heritage Foundation
website amidst the suffering crisis in
Haiti offers opportunities to the US in
addition to providing immediate
humanitarian assistance the US response
to the tragic earthquake in Haiti in
Haiti offers opportunities to reshape
Haiti's long dysfunctional government
and economy as well as to improve the
image of the United States in the region
and then goes on now I don't know
whether things are improving or not
because it shook the Heritage Foundation
13 days before they
issued 32 free market solutions for
Hurricane Katrina we put that document
up on our website as well it was closed
down the housing projects turned the
Gulf Coast into a tax-free free
enterprise zone get rid of the labor
laws that forces contractors to pay a
living wage yeah so it took them 13 days
before they did that in the case of
Katrina in the case of Haiti they didn't
even wait 24 hours now I say I don't
know whether it's improving or not is
that two hours ago they took this down
so somebody told them that it wasn't
couth and then they put up something
that was much more delicate
fortunately the investigative reporters
at Democracy Now managed to find that
earlier document in a Google cache but
what you'll find now is a much gentler
things to remember while helping Haiti
and buried down there it says long-term
reforms for Haitian democracy and its
economy are also badly overdue but the
point is we need to make sure that the
aid that goes to Haiti is one grants not
loans this is absolutely crucial this is
an already heavily indebted country this
is a disaster that as Amy said on the
one hand is nature is you know an
earthquake on the other hand is the
creation is worsened by the poverty that
our governments have been so complicit
in deepening crises natural disasters
are so much worse in countries like
Haiti because you have soil erosion
because the poverty means people are
building in very very precarious ways so
houses just slide down because they're
built in places where they shouldn't be
built all of this is interconnected but
we have to be absolutely clear that this
tragedy which is part natural part
unnatural must under no circumstances be
used to one further in that Haiti and to
to push through unpopular corporatist
policies in the interest of our
corporations and
is not a conspiracy theory they have
done it again and again so you know it
this is when you need to be vigilant and
frankly this is why I wrote the book
because the whole point is that in these
moments of crisis we are you know
everybody just wants to help and we want
to say send money send money and of
course send money but we also need to
send these political messages at the
same time do not use aid as a tool to
control further and especially because
we also have a c-span audience here and
we thanks he spend for covering this in
talking about the thesis of shaft
doctrine especially disaster capitalism
it's not something that most people
frame the world by and you truly
shattered a paradigm when you came out
with this book well the piece of the
book is that these policies of
deregulating the labor market
privatizing basic services like health
and education these are unpopular
policies and during during a times of
non crisis it is very hard for
politicians to get these policies
through certainly not all at once and so
there is a body of literature in
particularly among Chicago school
economists about the interrelationship
between what they call crisis and reform
and about how economists need to be
aware that in moments of crisis it one
is able to use the emergency atmosphere
to push through unpopular reforms all at
once and this has been you know this is
this is this is what the World Bank and
the International Monetary Fund have
been doing for 30 years very clearly I
mean why did the country come to the IMF
in the first place because they're
having an economic crisis right and the
whole idea of structural adjustment is
based on the premise the country comes
to the IMF on its knees says you know we
need help and the IMF has all the power
and they say fine we'll give you a loan
but in exchange for that loan you need
to privatize your electricity company in
your telephone company and
open it up to competition which means
foreign multinationals and you need to
liberalize your labor market and you
need to liberalize your banking sector
and all these things what I write about
in the Shock Doctrine is that the crises
that are being exploited to push through
these policies are getting bigger it
isn't only an economic crisis now it is
also natural disasters and you know I
write about how I think a really
important precedent for this was also in
our hemisphere which was hurricane Mitch
which was 1998 which devastated Central
America and the World Bank and the
International Monetary Fund directly
tied the aid to the countries hit by
Hurricane Mitch two demands that they
private this is Honduras Guatemala
privatized electricity privatized water
phones and also introduced very
controversial land reform policies this
has nothing to do with responding to the
crisis it's just that when you have
money that people need you have power
this is something that the US Treasury
doesn't seem to understand because when
they were handing out trillions of
dollars to the bay they didn't think it
was a good idea to put any conditions on
it but they actually could
as we talk about the banks Raj lay out
your thesis and the value of nothing um
well I mean it I mean it's becoming
abundantly clear that the free markets
or free market capitalism has let us
down and it was shocking to me to see
Alan Greenspan in October 2008 admit
that there was a flaw in in in in the
ideology that he thought had been
working quite well for 40 years um
thanks al Democracy Now or Gwen we had
Raj on the other day just put Raj's name
in or put Raj and Alan Greenspan
together and please don't can we play
and we play an excerpt of Henry Waxman
questioning Alan Greenspan as he Alan
Greenspan talks about the flaw and was
thinking and of course we're confronted
with this floor and the way the
mainstream media dealt with it was Alan
Greenspan got it wrong a movie at 11:00
and there wasn't really a deep
engagement with actually this is one of
the signs of free market policy having
to take it back and now of course you
know the the way the Chicago School
after a period of reflection and and
panic has responded is to say well of
course we got it wrong because markets
weren't free enough and that's you know
that that's their official response but
just for a moment Alan Greenspan kind of
offered a break and I don't think we're
equipped to know how to deal with that I
I mean as I say in the book I mean it we
wake up being told that actually this
philosophy of free-market ideology as
has a floor um and it's like in in Kafka
in metamorphosis where after a night of
bad dreams Gregor Samsa wakes up to find
himself in the body of a cockroach
um and
and in that but you know in that story
what's what what does Gregor Samsa do
he doesn't wonder well how the hell did
I end up as a girl in the body of a
cockroach
he doesn't wonder well what am I going
to wake up as tomorrow uh what he
worries about is his job and in the
sense you know that's entirely
reasonable right we wake up the
economy's falling around falling apart
behind around us
we're told that actually the system's it
doesn't work and of course we worry
about our jobs but it's also a chance to
think about how how the markets went
wrong and what we might replace them
with and so in the book I sort of spend
some time talking about where the flaws
in the free market in free market
fundamental doesn't come from how the
ideology will came became triumphant
well then in the second half of the book
look at different ways in which we can
value things without sticking price
price labels on them I mean the impulse
is just it we can only value things if
you if the market has passed judgment on
how much it is worth and a scribe to
dollar value but there are other forms
of valuing that the don't involve prices
the the the latest Nobel Prize in
Economics in part was won by Elinor
Ostrom for her work on the Commons now I
talk in the book about how Commons
becomes a way in which we can value
things together where we have resources
and rules for governing those resources
but I also talk about how actually
Commons were forged in struggles around
capitalism and they continue to be
stroke forged and struggles around
capitalism Elinor Ostrom didn't win a
prize for fighting capitalism she's you
won a prize merely for describing the
process of the comment but in the book
you talk a lot about some of the other
movements that around the world offer a
great deal of inspiration in terms of
figuring out other ways that we might
value things and thereby actually offer
a way of getting to the heart of this
the quote that defines the book that the
people today know the price of
everything and the value of nothing and
that of course is an Oscar Wilde quote
an Oscar Wilde people should know was a
socialist
it's just important to say the word you
know without the vegetables being thrown
it socialism ladies and gentlemen and
again I mean that the purpose of the
book is just being that it's it's okay
to say it I mean and in many ways the
alternatives have been suppressed I mean
when did you know for example that the
Dalai Lama has said I am a Marxist monk
it doesn't get reported yeah we need
sort of arms around Richard Gere or
usually Richard Gere's arms around here
it this is not this is not something
that features and of course it's
important that the Dalai Lama say I am a
Marxist monk because here's someone
who's been confronted with the full
power of a so-called communist State
against the Chinese government and you
would you would fully expect someone
who'd been up against the Chinese state
in the way that he has to be to be
hateful of Marxism but it actually
there's more about social justice and
about fairness and equality in Marx than
there is in the writings of Milton
Friedman and you would expect therefore
a little bit more interest but those
those some of those ideas are anything I
tried to pull them together about these
different movements but start by talking
about the value of a hamburger um so
what one of the one of the ways to start
thinking about how markets miss price
the way that we live is to look at but
to look at food I spend a lot of time
thinking about food and um a hamburger
when we confronted in the stores is what
for four bucks if you you know if you
buy it at your local burger joint um but
it research is an India little while ago
did some work on how much it would cost
if you fully incorporated the
environmental cost and they looked at if
this burger was once grown it was grown
on pasture and that pasture once upon a
time used to be rainforests then it's
possible to impute a dollar value to the
stuff you lose by deforesting and you
lose biodiversity you lose the carbon
that's sequestered in the forest you
lose the oxygen that's being produced
you lose a range of ecosystemic services
and if you if you were to impute a
dollar value to that that value would be
200 bucks and that's just for $200 per
hamburger just for the environmental
costs but there are other things that
are not included in in prices for
example if that hamburger is consumed in
the United States then the chances are
the tomatoes in that Hamburg are grown
in southern Florida and many of them
many of you may know about the coalition
of Immokalee Workers of workers in
southern Florida who picked Tomatoes who
are in conditions of modern-day slavery
now I don't use that term likely I mean
it is you know over a thousand people
have been freed under the statute that
the constituted abolition in the United
States I mean a thousand people freed
from conditions where they are chained
in the back of trailers that they where
they are forced to pay for showers five
dollars have to have a shower and
they're picking pestis thing a pesticide
so tomatoes all day and some people find
it cheaper to wash their hands in Bleach
than to pay the five dollars for a
shower
these are heinous conditions and of
course the labor is is that the cost of
labor rarely features in in the price of
a hamburger and then of course there a
range of costs that follow after the
hamburger that the costs that for
example are involved in the way that we
eat today
one in five healthcare dollars in the
United States is spent treating someone
with diabetes 187 billion dollars a year
that's due in no small part to the costs
associated with the way we eat and again
we don't pay that when we pay off four
dollar hamburger so market
systematically you know the hide the
real costs are things and there are
movements that there are fighting to get
those costs back in everything from as I
say the coalition of Immokalee Workers
to you know I mean the capitalism for
example systematically excludes the
costs of women's labor in capitalism
takes an ongoing subsidy from from the
reproductive labor that usually women
perform in terms of raising children of
taining community and if you added all
that up as UN researchers did in 95 that
you get a very big bill indeed 17
trillion dollars half the total world's
output is is premise on unpaid women's
labor and so and one of the most
inspiring movements for me is the la Via
Campesina the peasant way is this
coalition of 150 million farmers farm
workers and peasants around the world
and they have a vision of economic
justice of leveling the inequalities in
power called food sovereignty and if you
want to know more about it Wikipedia has
a very good definition of food
sovereignty um but but but I think
everything I mean the power of this kind
of counter movement can be found in in
the slogan the food sovereignty is about
an end to all forms of violence against
women
food sovereignty is about an end to all
forms of violence against women
now that's given that's a radical vision
I mean it's it starts with the idea of
sort of food production of about people
being able to control the food system
but it takes the idea that there's
inequalities in power from the household
to the IMF and the World Trade
Organization and talks about that the
violence against the structural violence
against women as well as domestic
violence but the structural violence
that prevents women from selling selling
their product on in the market for be
able to send their girls to school being
able to actually have a so-called level
playing field and for me this idea of
food sovereignty is is is where there's
a great deal of hope and a great deal of
promise in terms of reining in the
market blindness Anton's blindness um
took there's a neurological disease that
you get when you have a stroke or when
you have a traumatic brain injury if you
have Anton's blindness you are
cortically blind the signals from your
eye don't go to the back of your head
but but what what people with Anton's
blindness I mean you can tell that
people have Anton's blinds because
although they are cortically blind they
insist that they can see so if you have
Anton's blindness you are cortically
blind but you insist that you you have
vision and again and I use this is a
metaphor for talking about how we move
in our economy because again we've been
told that markets aren't working for us
um but we make excuses for markets we
can fabulet and in fact you can diagnose
Anton's blindness because when you're on
gist suspect someone has Anton's
blindness but you can imagine it with
people with Anton's blindness tend to
bump into things right
they are blind but they'll they'll
stumble along into something and then
they will make up a story about why why
this thing I was just being careless I I
didn't move that there um and these
confabulations
become a way of diagnosing the disease
now actually that's a metaphor for the
way that we we've moved in our economy
we've we're making excuses for the
failure of market market capitalism well
we say well we should have had more
regulation who allowed Bernie Madoff to
run off with our money we make these
sort of little stories around the edge
but we miss the fundamental problem that
actually we believe that we can see
through markets but actually we see very
little and we need to develop other ways
of sensing and valuing that aren't about
this faulty Faculty of market
fundamentalism
just a few of the reasons after we have
our discussion you should get a copy of
the value of nothing and by the way
everyone will be signing books
afterwards and we encourage you to ask
questions on those index cards I think
they were passed out or they will be if
you'd like to ask a question very good
and we'll come to them soon
but Naomi we were just together at the
end of December at this remarkable world
gathering in Copenhagen for two weeks
what some called the most important
diplomatic summit in history over an
issue that in this country does not get
very much attention but in the rest of
the world is a grave concern and
essential point for organizing it was
hard to go to any event at the this
global climate change summit without
seeing Naomi Klein on the stage
everywhere from the Bella Center to the
People summits outside whether she was
moderating event or giving a speech
you were really central to this whole
event Naomi talked about the
significance of it well you know
Copenhagen I'm really I'm really glad I
went I I spoke at the opening of clima
forum about my climate guilt having a
having flown there and any argument that
I made was that the fact that many of us
had you know a lot of people came there
on you know solar-powered buses and
things like that but certainly those of
us from North America didn't swim and
and that really the onus was on us
because of that to just work like crazy
to make this summit meaningful to
challenge the corporate takeover of the
environmental movement which was really
just so stark it inside the official
forum
to challenge all the false solutions to
climate change that are upstaging the
real solutions the only solutions to
climate change but really do involve
changing some of the things we do we
can't you know we can't just trade our
way out of this as as so many
politicians would have us believe and so
the argument that I made at clima forum
that first night was that if we really
did our work if we if we really made our
voices heard this would be the the
mother of all carbon offsets and and it
was an extraordinary two weeks I have to
say I think Democracy Now did absolutely
unbelievable work
and really you know what to me it's
never been clear how crucial democracy
now is then during those two weeks
nobody nobody else in the US media was
it's certainly not in the broadcast
media was making the commitment to this
issue and it's funny when you're in one
of these gatherings you know to you this
is the only story in the world right
because it feels like everybody must be
talking about it but then you hear from
your friends back home actually it's
kind of barely making the front page and
you know it's fairly making the news and
that was what was so wonderful about
what Democracy Now did which is just
decide this is the most important story
and we are going to go to Copenhagen and
bring the whole staff bring the whole
broadcast and broadcast live from from
the summit you know would have been nice
if some of the major networks did that
they didn't and so you know I I'll just
talk of it you know it's the most
important diplomatic event of the year
of the in the world in history you know
a lot of that was coming from the UN and
coming from the politicians I guess six
months ahead when they thought that they
were going to get a decent deal by the
time the summit itself rolled around
everyone was lowering expectations
certainly US politicians there'll be
more summits don't worry it's no big
deal you know after after they had been
saying it's one last chance to save the
world and we're good at odd stir and I
quoted him in Rolling Stone said that he
compared the the u.s. to he said we need
to summon the superhero spirit and it's
like a meteor is hurtling towards Earth
and yeah but by the time Copenhagen
rolled around he was also lowering
expectation
sorry chief US negotiator um for the
Obama administration but what was it was
exciting about Copenhagen was just the
force of of civil society but also to me
that climate change really changed
decisively in the discourse certainly
the discourse of the official discourse
around climate change from being I don't
know I think what people tend to think
of environmental
tschüss is sort of a luxury issue and
something that people who have time on
their hands can worry about what
happened in copenhagen is that the
global south roared and said this is
about poverty this is about justice this
is about debt and put this issue of
climate debt decisively on the global
agenda and climate that for those of you
who don't know is the argument the basic
argument that is really the facts are
not controversial the facts are these
twenty percent were set between 17 and
20 percent of the world's population
living in developed countries living in
countries like the US and Canada and
Australia are responsible for between 75
and 80 percent of the emissions that
created the climate crisis because they
weren't just created this year they were
created over a period of two hundred
years so 20% creates eighty percent of
the emissions according to the leading
World Bank economists on on this issue
the effects of climate change are being
felt overwhelmingly in the developing
world so what he says is that 75 percent
of the effects of climate change are
being felt in the poorest parts of the
world so you have a direct inverse
relationship between cause and effects
between who is creating this crisis and
who is living the effects so here you
know in this country we are feeling
pretty relaxed about climate change
having lots of debate about whether it's
real or not meanwhile temperatures are
rising dramatically in in Africa the
droughts are already here we're not
talking about grandchildren we're
talking about now I think Bill McKibben
said you know one thing I want if
there's one message to take home from
Copenhagen it's that it's not about your
grandkids it's about now
it's about islands facing extinction
within 50 years it is about the fact
that Manila was underwater hurt just a
couple of months ago
an extraordinary flood that is directly
connected to climate change that India
was battered this year by these bizarre
cyclones going in between droughts and
flooding droughts and flooding this is
happening all around the world so when I
say the southward in Copenhagen what
happened in Copenhagen and we heard this
from the chief negotiator of the g77 the
developing country block was the people
who created this crisis have to bear the
burden of solving the crisis and also
pay for that what it's going to take to
solve this crisis which both means
adapting to climate change making a
country's more resilient to extreme
weather and here if we look at Haiti and
what's happening there even though
that's not linked to climate change what
you could you can see what that would
mean why is Haiti in so much trouble
right now a big part of it is because
they don't have first responders they
don't have the infrastructure to respond
to the crisis so we need to have be
helping to pay for that because that is
part of responding to climate change and
of course we also need to be helping
countries leapfrog over fossil fuels to
greener technologies greener sources of
energy which have heavy upfront cost and
a lot of that has to do with technology
so you can't talk about responding to
climate change without talking about
loosening intellectual property laws
entrenched by organizations like the
World Trade Organization can you just
explain when you say these countries
like islands face extinction with the
rise of temperatures explain one because
we're talking about low low-lying
islands at the mall does Tuvalu because
because as glaciers melt the waters rise
and if they're low-lying islands it's
already happening it's already happening
to Tuvalu where they're losing landmass
very very quickly
Bangladesh I mean this is also a similar
to what's going on in Haiti in terms of
seeing the connection between bad
agricultural policies bad export-driven
agricultural policies and vulnerability
to climate change
in the context of Haiti you see it with
soil erosion and what that means when a
hurricane hits or when an earthquake
and how people's homes are destroyed so
it's more quickly than they would
otherwise be Bangladesh the World Bank
has been pushing shrimp farming very
very hard export driven shrimp farming
so mangroves which form a natural
barrier when storms come have been wiped
out in in in huge parts of the country
in order for Bangladesh to pay their
World Bank debts Raj knows much more
about this than me and he can correct me
if I'm getting this wrong but so you
have this you have these layers of of
debts building up in these countries
where you have a kind of an ecological
debt from these World Bank policies
these bad environmental policies
destroyed the natural barriers the
mangroves and then when climate change
hits when the storms start coming fast
and furious the natural barrier isn't
there so Bangladesh starts losing
landmass and that's what's happening
there
so the the what was extraordinary about
about Copenhagen was that the developing
country block the g77 made this demand a
repayment of climate debt Kida man and
there are some people here tonight from
the from the bolivian delegation Bolivia
was extraordinary in Copenhagen a small
country that doesn't usually sort of
make news in these international summits
came to Copenhagen with a really radical
really transformative set of demands and
and Bolivia has really been leading the
charge on this idea that climate debt
can can be an alternative to the way we
deal with the climate crisis because it
isn't just about saying you're bad you
did bad things you owe us money this is
the way the Western press has been
reporting on it one of the things that
was really clear coming from the climate
justice movement in Copenhagen was the
message that actually you can't put a
dollar amount on the loss of landmass in
Bangladesh on the loss of glaciers in
Bolivia on the fact that the capital
city of Bolivia La Paz is quite possibly
going to be facing a very severe
water crisis a shortage of drinking
water within le like the next 30 years
or less and and this is this is because
of climate changes the landlocked
country its water comes from the
glaciers if the glaciers melt the
country loses its drinking water how do
you put a price on that
how do you put a price on that you can't
and you shouldn't but we can talk about
justice and what an hella Cannavaro
who's that was the climate negotiator
for for Bolivia and the in the lead-up
to these negotiations was talking about
was a Marshall Plan for planet Earth and
this is a really exciting idea because
it isn't just the punitive idea it is
that by acknowledging that we that we
owe these debts and by the way this is
not a bizarre far-out idea this is
nothing more than the polluter pays
principle that is enshrined in US law
and and and and that has been used on
under mechanisms like the super fund
that polluters should pay for the
effects of their practices in this case
we are the polluters and this doesn't
necessarily mean that taxpayers have to
pay the burden it can be levied from
corporations which it should be levied
from corporations it shouldn't be
regular people who are paying this
climate debt but the debt is real
and with those resources we could be
solving our two most pressing crises at
once which is massive inequalities
between north and south and also the
climate crisis by putting real resources
behind this transformation from fossil
fuels to cleaner energies and I think
it's a really inspiring idea I don't
think it's a punitive idea and and that
to me was it was worth the trip to
witness that and and to be part of that
spectacular moment that was completely
ignored in the US for us the solution in
the United States that people talk about
is carbon trading although that is being
debated now you have this big carbon
trading summit that's been taking place
these last few days actually here in New
York and interestingly James Hansen the
NASA climatologist when the leading
climatologists in the world held a news
conference he's very much against
climate trading doesn't see that as an
answer he wrote an op-ed piece in The
New York Times and then Paul Krugman
wrote an op-ed piece basically saying
Jim go back to your science you're a
great climatologist but you don't know
what you're talking about when it comes
to carbon trading that is the answer
Raj Patel I wanted to ask you about the
value of carbon well yeah I mean explain
what carbon trading is well I mean
essentially what I mean the idea behind
carbon trading is that when you I mean
it's it's all premise on this idea that
the the EMPA that the that we live it
we're living in a tragedy of the common
now a tragedy of the Commons if people
don't know that it was an article
written in 1968 by a soil scientist
called Garret Hardin which he published
as a thought experiment the thought
experiment is that if you imagined that
we're all yeah we all live around a
forest and we all we enjoy trees and we
enjoy using trees and so because we're
all selfish individuals and no one owns
the forest we're going to go in and chop
those trees down and then we will take
them back and we will carve them and
burn
and do whatever it like it is we're
going to do with those trees and we'll
keep going back into the forest but the
tragedy is that our selfish desires
overrun any possibility of us sustaining
and managing that that forest and
because no one owns the forest and can
tell us to bugger off we will continue
to use that forest and destroy it and
the tragedy is that with eyes wide open
we will destroy the resource on which we
depend we will we will saw the branch
off that we're sitting on now that's the
tragedy of the Commons and I mean talk
about from the book actually that that's
nothing like the way Commons used to be
in fact but we're not just selfish
greedy individuals we are we are adapted
to be much more than that
we are sociable we are generous we are
cooperative we can be altruistic but the
idea the idea that if you own something
you will take care of it and if it is
unknown then it is unmanageable it's
kind of the driving idea behind this
idea of carbon trading that one you
privatize the right to pollute when you
give industry that the right to pollute
the atmosphere and you gently ratchet
that that right down that the market
will allocate resources so that the
capacity to pollute is is that the
atmosphere is priced correctly it's
likely under Woody Allen line I am at
two with nature
he has idea that he can't be at one with
nature he's when he says I'm at two with
nature I mean essentially what what I
divine carbon training is that you
respect the environment but then of
course you go and trade away the right
to despoil it and to destroy it and yeah
there are sites that parody this like
cheat neutral you know that the the
website where people have having
difficulty maintaining fidelity in their
relationships can can buy offsets for
the way that they for cheating from
people who are very good at being
monogamous um but I mean the trouble is
that I mean in theory it could work in
theory if there were market if if if
yeah if there were ways of transferring
things if if the infrastructure were in
place
if we lived in in some in some sort of
perfect textbook world perhaps carbon
trading could work in the real world it
never can and in fact if you look at the
examples of carbon trading that have
already been established in Europe
they've been pretty bad the the in the
book I quote drawn a the work of Larry
Loman who is a tremendous climate change
activists and and they managed to quote
someone from Citigroup
one of the the analyst at Citigroup
who'd been who've been analyzing cat can
gather the European emissions trading
scheme and his summary was yep looking
at the winners and losers from carbon
trading the winners were polluting
industries particularly coal a nuclear
one big out of carbon trading from the
free the free emissions permits they got
the biggest winners of course were banks
that the banks that have been making you
know that have been making a great deal
of money shifting these things around as
why Goldman Sachs is very very excited
about what what could be a multi
trillion dollar market in carbon
emissions and of course this cap and
trade that the emissions trading shares
the same DNA with the derivatives
trading that got us into such trouble
earlier on you know a couple of years
ago we should be suspicious of it for
that reason but empirically again you
know what we've seen is a banks making a
lot of money polluters making a lot of
money emissions are up and consumers are
worse off in Europe people just really
don't get carbon trading in a nutshell
um so so there are permits to pollute
and the government will ascribe the
permits to emit a certain amount of
carbon dioxide into the atmosphere and
if you're a polluting industry you will
do your best to try and get as many of
those permits you can for free but there
is a finite number of those permits and
so if you're if you're not reducing your
carbon emissions below the permitted
level you can buy permits from someone
who's actually doing a good job of
reducing the amount of carbon that they
produce so those permits then float
around in a market so that if you're
doing really badly you
by a permits to pollute from someone
who's doing a good job of not using
their allocation and again I mean it in
theory it sounds terrific except of
course it doesn't have it has a net
result of encouraging pollution isn't
this isn't a polluter pays principle
it's a polluter earns principle and
that's that's one of the reasons why
it's been so so deeply flawed in Europe
it's very easy to cheat I mean it's it's
ridiculously easy to cheat because how
do you establish that you that you are
doing a good job well you can you prove
that you are emitting less than you were
before or you were planning to emit so
you there might be you know you might
close a factory and move that factory
that fact we might become a contract
factory in China for instance this is a
big part of the reason why Europe's
emissions have gone down directly linked
to the decimation of their manufacturing
sector is it that those goods aren't
being produced anywhere no they just
moved the site of production right so
companies can claim well we've really
cleaned up our act when all that means
is that they've offshore their
manufacturing or they can say we were
planning to expand but we cut back and
then and it's kind of an honor system
well how do we know that they actually
were planning that is something that's
pretty easy to dr. so I think it is a
moment to be it's fair to be pretty
suspicious when we look at who the
people would be who would be regulating
this thing into the people who be would
benefiting you know okay so we want to
leave it you know to Tim Geithner and
Goldman Sachs and I'm sorry that sounds
like guilt by association but if they
cannot regulate the financial sector why
do we think that they can regulate
something as ephemeral as a carbon
sector but I think that that
the bigger issue is is Rajas other point
which is just that we're wasting time
and there is no urgency to the solution
and that is the biggest problem with it
it does not reflect the urgency that the
science tells us we should be feeling
that we need to be on a different course
by 2012 that's why this meeting should
have been so much more important than it
actually was
any measure that allows us to continue
as if nothing has changed to to to
continue our practices because we were
able to buy a few pollution credits from
somebody else that is wasting valuable
valuable time and I think that that's
the most important issue that we need to
focus on it you know I think certainly
the young people in the environmental
movement really know that and one of the
things that was really striking to me in
Copenhagen was you know people in their
early 20s who worked their butts off for
to get Obama elected and really believed
and and for them climate is the issue
you know it's the issue of their
generation is the issue of their lives
and they really believe that because
Obama recognizes that climate change is
real and unlike Bush of course he would
act with urgency and this is the problem
with Obama you know just because he can
reflect back because he can reflect back
to us what we believe he can say our own
arguments to us we assume he agrees with
us and is going to act accordingly but
no he's just like a mirror he's just
listed so
if I could change the subject a little
bit I think one of the things that has
happened to the progressive movements
left movement social movements in this
country that so much of it has been
absorbed into the electoral machine into
the neverending elections that this
country seems to go through and we have
seen you know an independent vibrant
anti-war movement be absorbed almost
completely into the Democratic machine
we saw it with the Kerry campaign it was
only democracy now my favorite Democracy
Now headline the idea this is just a
digression that the Boston Democratic
convention everybody was fawning over
Kerry democracy now his headline was
John Kerry delivers major pro-war
address but but it didn't matter right
you saw the anti-war movement working
their butts off for Kerry even though he
was running on a pro working that with
the headline we had for President
Obama's Nobel acceptance speech no I'm
not what was that one that was a major
pro war dress book but we changed her
name
we've all said that again and again that
you know we need to rediscover that
spirit that famous you know may be
apocryphal quote about FDR that he would
say to social movement leaders
progressive movement leaders you know
when they would present a good idea to
him about reforming legislation to be
better for workers he would say it
sounds like a good idea now get out
there and make me do it
I mean there was a dialectic a very
strong dialectic between social
movements independent trade unions and
that administration it was
confrontational and you know I think if
we've got if there's any hope of not
just sort of wallowing in cynicism in
this political moment on the one-year
anniversary of Obama's inauguration that
we need to we need to rebuild our
independent social movements and and
what I saw in Copenhagen I'm not among
the young environmentalist know their
science inside and out understand carbon
trading and why it won't work are
animated by this issue thought that
electing Obama was going to do it they
realize no we need an independent
movement that's going to push him and we
all need to realize that so I think if
that is one message we get from
Copenhagen than it was worth it okay
okay can i I mean just to follow I mean
I think that's right i mean it's ironic
that you know we had the president
elected on this as a mandate of change
and then as soon as the election was
over we were encouraged to you know to
sort of see him as you know the pizza
delivery guy have changed where we would
sit in front of our televisions and he
would bring shooting a hot fresh
steaming chain
and it's let me do that and of course me
whirring encouraged to be passive but
and and and and it was interesting to
see I'm sorry and patient and of course
yeah that's that's the great neoliberal
virtue isn't it patience the glue the
metaphor of your life well you know I
you know I do tend to stuff it into
everything but I mean the idea I mean
it's very interesting actually you
should mention food because I do think
the food movement in the United States
what I mean I think the food movement of
the United States is one of these things
but particularly under Bush where it was
possible for progressive politics to
make a real a real transformative change
and in fact it was interesting at the
beginning of the were at the end of the
1990s but people used to sort of mock
the United States for its absence of
thinking about food and certainly people
in Europe thought that the food movement
in the United States looked a lot like
that that scene in The Triplets of
Belleville they've you seen that there's
a sort of sort of slightly ponderous
Americans eating all the time and just
sort of waddling through streets um and
yet I mean in Europe now people look to
the United States for leadership
particularly around the food movement
and that I think is tremendously
exciting and early it's a sign of the
politicization that food has gone
through in the United States
and an example of the kinds of
grassroots democracy that are happening
and I know that there are members of the
brooklyn food collective here tonight
where i all who are we're getting
involved in activism around the child
nutrition reauthorization act and i
think the kinds of and that there is a
petition to be signed and I know that
that'll be available somewhere so please
do sign that but I mean I think the food
movement is an interesting way in which
these movements are happening right here
and I'm excited by the ways in which
things like food policy councils offer
ways of becoming democratic I mean I
think you're absolutely right that yeah
a lot of what we're in deuced to be when
we when we when we're democratic is you
get involved in a like
but of course we don't live in a
democracy we say I say this sometimes
that we live in a complain opera see
where you know we if we elect our
leaders and then after two years if they
disappointed us we'll will elect another
bunch of people who will then disappoint
us um but what we don't have is genuine
democracy and I think a Fenian democracy
for all it obvious I don't want to live
in happens with slavery and with withers
profound misogyny but what I do want the
classical Athenian democracy had an
interesting thing about it which which
is that it had no elections in in
Athenian democracy at the beginning of
every year 6000 people would be picked
at random to run the city and then they
would run the city for a year in groups
of 500 and then at the end of the year
they would be disbanded another 6000
would would be assigned at random it's
funny you should say that because Johann
Hari who's one of my favorite
journalists who works at the independent
he was covering the Copenhagen summit
and at one point he said to me that he
really believed that if the country
delegations had been selected like jury
duty just random citizens they
absolutely could have come up with the
brilliant you know but that's it I mean
oh I mean I and it was interesting to
see in in Copenhagen that it was elites
versus elites and I was curious about
your sense of the difference between you
know those elites contending against one
another with with Seattle so I I know
you were you're both protests and had a
chance to see you know to see things
really from all angles they're actually
funny it's one of the the my dirty
secrets is that I I was not actually at
Seattle because my editor wouldn't send
me over he didn't think was going to be
important so um I was stranded so we go
with a winter
but and I wrote about it but but I
wasn't there sadly um but you know I
think I think there were there were I
think the dynamics were really different
in that with Seattle and many of the
other two mega protests you know outside
the g8 or outside the the IMF World Bank
the people in the streets were just
flat-out opposed to what these
institutions stood for and their goals
whereas in Copenhagen the people in the
streets believed in the goals of the the
institution at least its stated goals
far more than the people inside so it
was it was it wasn't like Seattle in
that way I think what was interested
where there was an interesting parallel
was in Seattle you had an inside-outside
sort of pincer where there were the
people in the streets who were hood shut
down the city but then you also had the
developing country governments who were
in many ways emboldened by the protests
to stand up to the incredible bullying
from the US and the European Union to
say no to a bad deal so the reason why
the Seattle World Trade Organization
tops talks collapse was not because
there was a protest it was because the
the developing countries broke the deal
refused the deal and that dynamic was
certainly at play and at but I think
that there was much more interplay I
mean to talk about Bolivia again but not
just Bolivia I think with some of the
the developing countries that were
pushing some of some of the more
progressive policies there was much more
dialogue much more fluid like for
instance like as I said at hella
Cannavaro
the one of Bolivia's leading negotiators
came and spoke at clima forum and there
were there were there was there was
quite a lot of that and so did Ava
Morales and he also spoke at clima forum
I believe it was at clima forum right so
there was it was kind of less taking
sides as opposed
um I wanted to ask you Naomi about your
assessment of President Obama beyond the
issue of climate but on the issue of war
and also healthcare as a Canadian but
first Raj that introduction of you that
you work for the World Trade
Organization that you worked for the
World Bank and you've protested them on
four continents just give us a little
more fill that out a little bit I mean
that I will well I know that was we met
when you were along for know logo the
first time around but and I I mean I was
curious about the World Trade
Organization in the world by the World
Trade Organization I entered as an
intern just to see what it was like and
then I reported that to the peoples
global action that was having an anti
WTO camp at there in Brazil in Geneva
and and it was interesting I mean I
worked very hard on a as an intern I was
assigned a project of figure out whether
trade increases pollution and and the
answer is yes so and this apparently was
the wrong answer to put for the world
trade also I wrote this fantastic big
chunky report and they're like no thanks
and they tossed it out and they came up
with with some actually now discredited
economics about how there's something
called a kuznetsov about how actually
you know ruiz get richer they're they
produce less pollution and so there's a
sort of curve of war pollution and then
less polluting and of course that that
because they send it to a country and
then they yell at china for breaking
their climate summit righty-tighty Danny
this is the story that the world trade
ordinate but it was interesting to see
how that work the World Bank was
actually much more insidious I was there
I was doing as a graduate student at
Cornell and one of the professor's there
man called Ravi Campbell was working on
the world Development Report 2000 and I
I was one of his students he's like I've
got this project for you you get to look
at the World Bank's classified documents
and you get to see how they treat
poverty and you get to write about it
quick rip critically
like I'll do that classified document
I'm there um and and so you know we got
these documents arted coding them up and
then it turned out that what we were
encouraged to do was not to write an
honest assessment of what the World Bank
was doing but to write a puff piece and
and it was published as a under the
title of voices of the poor can anyone
hear us and I mean just to give you a
sense of what how awful this document
was the final paragraph it is a
narrative from a consultants classified
report and the report goes at this and
so as the Sun set on the African plains
we arrived in the village and the women
spontaneously got up and sang us a song
and the song was here at the World Bank
here of the World Bank they are here to
develop us we hope they won't forget us
end quote and the final line was will we
so so anyway and I resign and but that
is yeah that was published and but so
that's what I learned at the web I mean
basically what but but also when I
learned of the world Magni is that it's
not filled with sort of Blofeld young
villains you know sort of people sitting
in swivel chairs because of leather
chairs stroking cats except except
except for at the top um it's people by
people who believe they're doing the
right thing and who are yeah I mean we
were convinced of of the mission and
that's why actually what makes it much
more insidious is is that this is the
road to Hell being paved with good
intention my axe also believes they're
doing God's work yeah if someone would
bring forward the index cards we'll draw
a few of those questions but Naomi as
they do in the introduction your 10th
anniversary edition of no logo taking
aim at brand bullies which was so
important in documenting the grassroots
movements that came together around the
world 10 years ago you take on President
Obama today and if you could extend it
to war health care your assessment um
well the reason why I write about Obama
in the in the the updated version of the
book is that you know logo is is a book
about the resistance to corporate
culture but it is also a book about the
rise of branding and how that took over
the corporate world and the idea that
the central mission of corporations was
not to produce products and sell them
but to produce ideas and market them and
it didn't matter who produced their
products anymore they could outsource
them so what I argue in the book is that
there's a direct relationship between
the fact that we are experiencing
increasingly voracious aggressive
marketing culture and the fact that we
are being offered ever more casual jobs
because if a company decides that it is
in the idea of business and the
in the business of creating images and
ideas and not producing products then it
will have these effects they will pour
their resources into marketing and
design and they will extract resources
from manufacturing and try to have a
much more casual relationship with their
employees and I believe that Obama is a
super brand and that the Obama
phenomenon is is primarily a branding
phenomenon and you know I want to take
this outside of the question of whether
or not we prefer him to McCain okay you
know that debate is over personally yes
I prefer him to John McCain and that
said something really powerful happened
during that campaign where hopes and
dreams were projected onto this blank
canvas that was Obama that we can't just
blame on Obama it's about us I mean we
and I think in order to understand it we
need do need to understand how we do
this with branding how do we do this
with marketing I think the Obama machine
studied the way in which brands like
Nike and Starbucks and Apple have
managed to to become icons for young
people how they absorb the iconography
of transformative movements like the
civil rights movement when I saw that
video the will.i.am video for Obama I
looked at it in like I I mean I just
left I thought finally a politician can
make ads as good as Nike because it had
a nike quality to it of that you know
that invitation to imagine transcendence
and you think hey agrees with me but did
he really say anything really and so
that's why we're in this you know and
that's what good mark marketing does it
evokes the emotions but doesn't make the
commitment because you don't to be
helped to anything right and that's why
I think we are in an awkward situation
with with Obama where we can't really
just say oh he betrayed us he promised
these things because you know if you
look at what he actually said during the
election campaign you know he didn't off
he didn't promise single-payer health
care I would have liked it too but he
didn't okay he didn't promise to end the
war in Iraq he
promised to downsize and escalate in
Afghanistan and you know what that's
what he's doing right so we need to
understand that that a lot were
complicit in this exercise of mass
projection and rational exuberance I
mean he is acting like the brand that he
is and it is pretty precarious because
branding is success in the world of
branding one of the things like looking
back at no logo 10 years later and
updating it it was just like wow no one
talks about Tommy Hilfiger anymore I
mean a lot of these brands that were
sort of on top of the world 10 years ago
you know fell pretty quickly and I think
in the same way that Obama Obama's kind
of like a market bubble I mean he plated
really really quickly and he's prone to
deflation very quickly as well for that
reason I don't want to as I said you
know early I don't think we should just
give into the cynicism the thing that
I've said this before to say it again
think I don't like about Obama is the
same thing I like about Obama
I think he's open to pressure okay at
the moment he's being pressured by the
wrong people I don't think it's a
hopeless case I think I think it's a
better situation to have an Obama in
office who is open to pressure than it
is to have a Bush and Cheney you know
who's the famous you know that Cheney
moment that summed it up for me when he
was asked know two-thirds of the
American public are opposed to the war
in Iraq what's your response and he said
so right I mean Obama doesn't respond to
questions like that with so I'm if
anything he you know he would he's too
prone to changing his position because
of whatever they're saying on Fox News
at the moment but you know I think that
there's a real that this is this is a
moment when progressives really really
need to step up and I don't think we
have any reason to believe that he
wouldn't respond to pressure you know
obviously I think one of the things we
need to be pressuring for is radical
campaign finance reform because
that is I think that's the most it's the
most pressing issue in this country it
is the most pressing issue in this
country and and I think it's so urgent
because the alternative is just cynicism
you know Obama won this election when he
started talking about the economic
crisis and the gap between Main Street
and Wall Street he was losing the
election people forget this
but now when Sarah Palin entered the
scene she she they pulled ahead in the
polls in those first two scary weeks in
September it looked like we were going
to have a mccain-palin ticket that was
going to win and then Lehman collapse on
its September 14th and Obama started
connecting with the voters he hadn't
been able to connect with previously and
he said the system was broken and that
the system of deregulation and giving
more and more to the people at the top
and waiting for it to trickle down
wasn't working now of course he didn't
promise much he just said it so we
thought well he'll definitely do
something about that right and here we
are a year and a half into the economic
crisis and nothing has been solved
nothing has been solved the too big to
fail banks are even bigger the banks are
still leveraged to the teeth they are
still reaping enormous profits from
these high-risk debt mechanisms and of
course from the bailout itself which was
delivered without any strings attached
that moment of leverage was lost so why
is that there's a feed fundamental
feedback mechanism that is broken and
what is breaking it is corporate money
because Wall Street knows how to hedge
its risks that's one thing they know how
to do really really well and the way
they hedge their risks their political
risks is through campaign contributions
they make relatively small for them
contributions to political parties to
insure against the risk of political
change and it's paying off for them and
that's that is what we need to unblock
if there's going to be real change
whether it's health care frankly foreign
policy as well I think money is driving
foreign policy in a major way well
clearly you have inspired both of you
many people to ask questions and we
would be here for a very long time if we
went through them all but this is going
to be rapid-fire we have 15 minutes to
go
and then you can come up and talk to our
guests you can get books or not but it's
a great way to spend the whole time and
to get more books you have more time
with people because I don't actually
sign them so I'm going to just throw
these out and answer them if you can in
Oh a minute or a minute and a half and
we'll see if we could get through a lot
of them I'm going to start with taya
who's 8 years old who's making all the
pollution when are we going to know how
much damage that has been done um very
quickly we are the way we consume is
unsustainable the of course it opens are
the ones who are trying to profit from
that um but if you if you add up the way
that we've been consuming and the
damages that's caused in developing
countries over the past 40 years for
example and you lowball that figure if
you just make some very conservative
estimates we developing countries five
trillion dollars now of course the way
that we do the math is that developing
countries owe us that they are they owe
us a debt of 1.8 trillion dollars but
actually you know at fault is the way
that the richest countries have been
consuming over the past 200 years and
unfortunately we need to we need to
consume a fair share and we're just
we're consuming way more than our fair
share at the moment are either of you
involved in organizing students and us
college campuses to protest against the
price of tuition
I'm not involved in organized you just
win the Mario Savio award where you gave
an address at University of California I
gave the Mario Savio lecture which I
know you've given before for those of
you who don't know Mario Savio was one
of the leaders of the Free Speech
Movement at Berkeley in the 60s an
incredible speaker who when did he die
in the in the not too long ago and they
have established this Memorial Lecture
and it was great timing because they
always bring in activists speakers um
but I happen to be giving just by my
luck that the speech at a time when
Berkeley was in revolt and I think Raj
who lives in Berkeley could speak to
this more but so I'm not organizing
students but I tried to incite them as
much as I could but they were already
pretty incited the students throughout
the UC system are facing a 32 percent
tuition increase and it's it that their
libraries are being closed on weekends
there had just been a successful
occupation of the one of the libraries
on the Berkeley campus when I was there
because the university had closed the
libraries on Saturdays can you imagine
telling students they couldn't study on
Saturday so this group of students and
professors had had refused to leave the
library on Friday night and just stayed
there all night and they won that that
was good but yeah I think this amazing
amazing stuff going on in California and
I think California is the canary in the
coal mine for this whole economic crisis
which is not over and I've been saying
this since day one the crisis not being
solved it's being moved this was a
private debt crisis a private sector
debt crisis that was moved from Wall
Street to Washington we will take your
debts they're fine the recession is over
for Wall Street there have reaping
record bonuses but who is paying the
price the states are paying the price
because their tax bases are collapsing
why because we bailed out Wall Street
instead of Main Street Obama promised
that it wouldn't be a top-down bailout
that's exactly what it was a choice was
made to bail out Wall Street instead of
bailing out workers instead of bailing
out homeowners so what has that
and it's meant people are losing their
homes and huge numbers they're losing
their jobs and huge numbers and that
means they're not paying taxes so right
now the states across the board
California is facing a twenty five
billion dollar budget shortfall but
across the board the states are facing
an almost two hundred billion dollar
shortfall and this is when they're
getting stimulus money so when the
stimulus money runs out there's going to
be even more of a shortfall so how are
they dealing with it they're dealing
with it by massively increasing tuition
closing women's shelters that was one of
Schwarzenegger as great ideas at a time
when there's more and more violence
against women because there's more and
more economic stress so that's who's
paying for these Wall Street bonuses
that is the moral depravity of this of
this political
a very very quick coder to that in
shorts Naga in his State of the State
address announced that there would be a
was mooting a constitutional minimum out
to spend on education and a
constitutional maximum amount to spend
on prisons and and and I mean what his
office said that actually it was the
protests that the drove that because
again you know in the the the protesters
are saying that when the state is ready
to spend forty something thousand
dollars a year on housing prisoners but
a fraction of that on students there's
something wrong with the priorities so
you know protests were and I should say
that that women fought back over the
women's shelters and also one that so
when people fight back they they can win
the issue is that it's easier to fight
against Schwarzenegger you know who
still you know he's the right-wing
boogeyman that it is to fight against
Obama people don't know how to deal with
Obama well this is a follow up on that
where is the angry populist movement on
the left the militia movement and the
white supremacists are joining the tea
baggers on the right and co-opting the
Republican Party are we really ready to
follow an uprising from the right name
change needed a me since the financial
code amok racine ow should be democracy
me way back when but that issue of
organizing and it's taken up from
questioner after questioner any antidote
ideas
how can people organize they're all
following a similar theme well I mean
yet it mean it's all very well to write
books about why it's important to
organize but but actually the things
that are working well I mean again I
always come back to food but it's just
the fact of it particularly when there
are 49 million Americans going hungry
you know there's a need when the right
is is happy to actually parrot the
refrain that Obama said that the system
is broken and all of a sudden the
various kinds of racist fears are
stirred up I mean there's something the
tea baggers have that's worth taking
seriously it's not Fox News as their
oxygen but it is a genuine anger about
the situation that we're in now and it's
appalled to take to see how the right is
capitalizing on that
when it comes to food I mean when it
comes to the situation we're in right
now nothing works as an organizing tool
like success if one's interested in
building a movement then it's important
to have examples that work examples that
are meeting people's needs and what when
you have I mean the Black Panther Party
for self defense for example and as part
of its organizing tools things like
breakfasts so good absolutely you know
it was meeting social needs because the
state wouldn't meet them but but not
merely you know coming out as a social
service organization but using that to
leverage much more profound demand and I
think that's you know that there's only
so much in terms of sloganeering that
works but but it worked particularly as
I say around food you're seeing a lot of
a lot of organizing happening at the
grassroots level around feeding feeding
hungry Americans and it's not just
around food I mean you see these
movements happening around housing and
housing occupation you're seeing them
you're seeing them in education for
example as witnessed by the success of
what's been going on to some extent in
California and I think it you know I
think that the answer is there were
loads of examples of successful
organizing and it's the practical
success that helps recruit to a more
progressive project rather than good
slogans which I wish we have but well
this follows up on your concerns about
food on a member of a food co-op about
being a more responsible consumer of
food support organic and responsible non
industrial farming and promote farming
sustainability
apart from cooperatives what practical
things can open
Weller's entrenched and corporate
industrial retail food system do to help
change this unsustainable and
destructive food system um where do we
start
I mean there's certainly not buying
corporate industrial food is a good way
and you know and listen this is not this
is not just about food you know we're
hearing a lot about move your money dot
info for example and as consumers we can
move our money away from from the big
banks towards credit unions and things
like that back tremendously important to
do but if all we do is consume smarter
then you know then we do buy into this
you know this very American myth that we
can together save the world by shopping
and I think we need to recognize that
you know if we're fighting the
industrial food system we need to we
need to take political action because
otherwise you know corporations will
bend to you know to adapting to new
consumer environments we need to change
the actual political environment and
that means getting involved in
everything from the brooklyn food
coalition to getting involved in the
organizing around the next farm bill for
example which is already starting now
and if you'd like to know more about
that food first org has some great stuff
yes the childhood nutrition
reauthorization act is one of the big
things that's coming up this year and
again what I wanted to take you much
time the sign that signed the letter and
learn out learn more from the brooklyn
food coalition be honest with the high
level of apathy and the world population
and the entrenched power of corporations
what hope do we really have to save us
you um you know I think hope is is a
choice that we make because the
alternative is not acceptable so you
know I don't think we are you know we're
not making a it's not a mathematical
equation here and you know I don't I'm
surprised to hear questions like that at
events like this because you know why
bother coming to an event like this if
that's what you think and I'm hope it
you know in in that I think coming to an
event like this is an act of hope people
wanted you know you could read you can
read at both of our books you don't have
to come to a roomful of people to talk
it's because we want to connect with
each other we have to we have to rebuild
our social networks and and this is the
truth that we are living in the wreckage
of a failed economic model that hasn't
just taken away jobs and security it has
decimated so many of the infrastructures
that use to bring us together that's why
you know spaces like the Society for
ethical culture and I've had many
wonderful evenings in this space are so
important we don't have a lot of spaces
like this that are devoted to to public
discourse for ethical culture think
about the name right you know even on
University campuses I hear more and more
from students that on their own campuses
they're being charged for space right
for extracurricular activities which is
something that would have been totally
unheard of so you know I I think it's
easy to feel hopeless particularly when
you're at home watching television but I
think things can change very very
quickly when when we change the power
dynamics you know they're a few and we
are many and that's why that's why
social movements are such a perennial
threat and that's why this consumer
model whether it's the consumer model of
politics of just voting and weighting or
shopping your way out of everything you
know are they're all attacks on the idea
of social organizations whether they're
trade unions or neighborhood
associations and you know Raj and I have
both
looked at different models of organizing
and in in the developing world in
particular where neoliberalism has this
economic model which is called
neoliberalism outside of this country
has has already done so much damage that
the organizing models in response to it
are in many ways more developed and we
made this film in Argentina a few years
ago about occupied factories is a way
that that country which had previously
been held up as this model of economic
development to the rest of Latin America
the model student for the International
Monetary Fund the bottom fell out and
and people people responded in in a
range of really inspiring ways including
turning their workplaces into
cooperatives that rather than letting
them close and letting the factories be
the machines be auctioned off people
occupied their factories said our bosses
might not want them but we think that we
can run them we don't need huge profits
we just need jobs we need to be able to
feed our families so and and the other
thing is that people really learned
neighborhood based organizing and there
was a slogan in Argentina which is
really stuck with me and it came from
the industrial belts in Buenos Aires
where there used to be a lot of
manufacturing and the manufacturing all
closed so they said the new factory is
the barrio the new factory is the
neighborhood and and and that's the way
they treated the neighborhoods as if
they were workplaces and did that kind
of door-to-door organizing that is
required and and built movements of
unemployed people and you know that's
that's happened around the world and
it's it's happening in this country but
on a much smaller scale well
on that note and again going back to the
beginning of this evening in these very
dire times as we look at what's
happening in Haiti I think we have to
ask ourselves can we really afford not
to do anything if not for yourselves for
people who need your help here and in
other places to ensure that people have
the ability to organize on their own and
it really does begin right here in this
room and in every other gathering place
where we talk where we organize and
commit ourselves to making the world a
better place and I can't think of a more
wonderful religious experience than well
these words the place where people meet
to seek the highest is holy ground we
have a lot of work to do there's a lot
of suffering in the world a lot of
suffering even in this room and only
together if we organize can we ensure
that well maybe there'll be a little
less of that suffering and also support
independent media because it's the place
where we gather and now understand why
people say I listen to or watch
Democracy Now religiously well I think
that's here the place where people need
to seek the highest is holy ground do
something about Haiti and do something
to improve your own community and you'll
be making a big difference in the world
thank you
Amy Goodman is executive producer and
host of Pacifica radios Democracy Now
she's also a columnist for TruthDig for
more information visit TruthDig com Raj
Patel is a fellow at the Institute for
food and development food first and has
written for The Guardian and the Los
Angeles Times he's currently a visiting
scholar at the UC Berkeley Center for
African Studies for more information
visit Raj Patel org while researching
his book the Prohibition hangover
alcohol